well all you need is the top of a pin of
blood and within a few hours
metro police will have your dna
information that's how advanced
investigators have become when fighting
crime but that also has a downfall
christian kosovo got an inside look at
the department's forensic lab and their
efforts to keep up with demand
metro's forensic lab is one of two in
the state the lab works on a variety of
cases from homicides to property crimes
a task that sometimes is not done fast
enough for victims
clothing blankets guns the work done
with state-of-the-art technology behind
this glass wall
is mind-blowing we used to only get
about 16 percent success when we would
test dna from guns
currently with that technology we're
able to get an over 50 percent success
from dna from guns
kimberly murga is the director for the
laboratory services for metro
for her and her team the work is nonstop
in the past 12 months we've received
over 2
700 total requests for service on dna
we we've completed over 2 800
analyses in the past year currently we
have a backlog of about 1
700 forensic laboratory requests
specific to dna
among those requests the tamika williams
case the 41 year old was found
february in an apartment near downtown
las vegas
she was strangled danielle staple
executive director with the rape crisis
center
says one of the hardest things is
accepting there is little control anyone
has
on these situations often it is really
challenging particularly for parents we
offer support for
partners siblings dna from williams
hands
led to the arrest of 23 old shalom
duncan
while some families get justice staples
says others
do not especially with the data system
that's not just a local thing right
because we have people who
for example were assaulted here maybe as
guests to
our area and they may never have lived
here
with all the work the lab does there is
a need to keep that crime fighting
that's money in 2017 the approval of
ab-97
allocated a one-time fund of 2.3 million
dollars to mandate kids be submitted to
the forensic lab
for analysis within 30 days and
completed within 120 days
those funds are going to sunset in june
of this year
so right now one of the challenges we're
looking at
how do we bridge that gap a gap merga
says will reduce staff
and slow down the process a concern for
any victim
waiting for justice this summer the lab
will get a new tool which promises to
provide investigators with better leads
and answers to some cold case murders
and even current investigations
christian casa does 8 news now